KURDISTAN.
>> WELL, IT WAS MATTHEW CHANCE
REPORTING EARLIER FROM BELARUS.
THE AUTHORITIES ARE WAITING FOR
A DECISION BY GERMAN
AUTHORITIES, ALTHOUGH, IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHAT THEY MEAN BY THAT.
WHAT IS GOING ON, FRED?
>> Reporter: YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT, BECKY.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT EXACTLY THE
BELARUSIAN AUTHORITIES ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
THERE WAS A PHONE CALL THAT HAS
BEEN TALKED ABOUT A LOT IN
BELARUS AND STATE TV BUT SURELY
ALSO, BY THE BELARUSIAN
AUTHORITIES IN THE MIGRANT CAMP.
WILL ANY ACTION FOLLOW THAT?
THERE IS NO INDICATION THAT THE
GERMANS HAVE THE WILL TO TAKE
ANY OF THESE PEOPLE IN AND IN
FACT TWO DAYS AGO THE FOREIGN
MINISTER CAME OUT AND SAID THESE
PEOPLE NEED TO RETURN TO THEIR
COUNTRY'S OF ORIGIN.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS OTHER
TALKS VERY DIFFICULT TO SAY AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
ONE THING IS DEFINITELY CLEAR,
THE POLLS CERTAINLY ARE NOT
GOING TO LET ANYBODY PASS
THROUGH THAT BORDER CROSSING,
PASS THROUGH THAT BORDER.
THEY ARE UNEQUIVOCAL ABOUT THAT
AND NOW THAT PRESSURE IS
ALLEVIATED FROM THE BORDER
CROSSING WITH A LOT OF THOSE
PEOPLE GOING TO THE CENTER WHERE
MATTHEW WAS AT AND LEAVING THE
CAMP AT THE BORDER, THE POLLS
SAY THEY BELIEVE THEY HAVE
PREVAILED IN THIS FIRST WAVE OF
AN ATTACK, A HYBRID ATTACK ON
THE BOARDER.
IN FACT, THE POLISH INTERIOR
MINISTER FIRM BELIEVES AND
POLAND SEES NATO AND THE E.U.
ARE IN THE CORNER AND WILL
CONTINUE TO HANDLE THE SITUATION
EXACTLY THE WAY IT HAS BEFORE.
AS FAR AS THE EUROPEAN UNION IS
CONCERNED, AND AT LEAST STARTING
TO PROVIDE SOME AID FOR THOSE
PEOPLE NOW THEY HAVE ALLOCATED
700,000 EUROS THEY SAY TO
ALLEVIATE SUFFERING.
IN THE LONG TERM, THERE ARE SO
MANY PEOPLE STILL STUCK INSIDE
BELARUS.
THERE IS A FLIGHT THE IRAQI
GOVERNMENT SCHEDULED TO FLY
MAYBE 200 PEOPLE OUT ON
THURSDAY, BUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN
AFTER THAT WHETHER THE FOLKS
THAT ARE THERE AT THAT
PROCESSING CENTER AND ELSEWHERE
IN BELARUS WILL BE WILLING TO GO
HOME IN THE MEDIUM TERM
ABSOLUTELY UNCLEAR AT THIS POINT
IN TIME, BECKY.
>> FRED PLEITGEN IS ON THE
POLISH SIDE OF THE BORDER AND
REPORTING SOME 1,000 MIGRANTS UP
AGAINST THAT RAZOR WIRE ON THE
BELARUS SIDE OF THE BORDER.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO MONITOR WHO IS
GOING ON.
>>> THE U.S. IS GROWING
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
MIGRANT BUILDUP ALONG THAT
BORDER AND WHAT THAT MEANS FOR
THE WIDER SECURITY SITUATION IN
EASTERN EUROPE.
OVER THE WEEKEND, THE U.S. STATE
DEPARTMENT SPOKESMAN CALLED THE
BORDER CRISIS AN EFFORT TO
DISTRICT ATTENTION FROM RUSSIA'S
TRUE BUILDUP ON ITS BORDER WITH
UKRAINE.
NATO ALSO WARNING RUSSIA OVER
THAT BUILDUP OF TROOPS.
WE'VE SEEN THIS AGAIN AND AGAIN
WITH RUSSIA KEEN TO EXPLOIT
OPPORTUNITIES TO SCORE
GEOPOLITICAL POINTS AND TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF PERCEIVED POWER
VACUUMS.
TAKE THIS REGION FOR EXAMPLE.
MANY I'VE SPOKEN TO TELL ME THAT
RUSSIA STOLE THE SHOW, FRANKLY,
AT THIS DUBAI AIR SHOW TAKING
PLACE A COUPLE OF KILOMETERS
FROM WHERE WE ARE TODAY WHEN IT
SHOWED OFF ITS NEWEST FIGHTER
JET, THE SU 75 CHECK MATE.
THAT PLANE IS MEANT TO RIVAL THE
AMERICAN F-35 A PLANE MANY
COUNTRIES IN THIS REGION HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO BUY FOR YEARS,
PROPOSED U.S. SALE OF F 35s HAS
BEEN SLOWED SINCE PRESIDENT
BIDEN TOOK OFFICE.
MY NEXT GUEST COULDN'T BE BETTER
PLACED TO DISCUSS ALL OF THESE
REGIONAL MILITARY IMPLICATIONS.
HE OVERSEES THE U.S. STATE
DEPARTMENT'S FOREIGN MILITARY
WEAPONS SALES AND SHE JOINS ME
NOW.
I WANT TO START BY THANKING YOU
AND FOR JOINING US TONIGHT.
YOU'VE BEEN AT THE DUBAI AIR
SHOW AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT YOU'VE SEEN AND THE
DISCUSSIONS YOU'VE BEEN HOLDING
THERE IN A MOMENT.
I WANT TO START UP WITH RUSSIA'S
IRREGULAR MILITARY MOVEMENTS
NEAR UKRAINE'S BORDER.
U.S. OFFICIALS SAID PUBLICLY IN
RECENT DAYS THAT THEY DON'T KNOW
YET WHAT RUSSIA'S INTENTIONS
ARE.
DO YOU SHARE THE CONCERNS THAT
THE TREND LINES ARE WORRYING AT
THIS POINT?
>> RUSSIA IS CLEARLY BEING
PROVOCATIVE ON THE BOARDER WITH
UKRAINE AND THAT IS WHY WE'RE
LOOKING FOR EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
HELP OUR UKRAINIAN PARTNERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR SECURITY
COMMITMENT TO THEM IS STRONG SO
THEY CAN DEFEND THEMSELVES AND
DETOUR A RUSSIAN BUILDUP.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT AN
INVASION?
>> WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT ANY
RUSSIAN BUILDUP ON THIS BORDER
BECAUSE AS YOU SAID, THEY DO
TAKE ADVANTAGE AND THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD UP AND THAT IS REALLY
CONCERNING TO ALL OF US.
>> WHAT'S THE CURRENT STATE OF
U.S. MILITARY AID TO UKRAINE AND
WHAT SORT OF HARBOR IS INVOLVED?
>> WE'VE SEEN SHIPMENTS OF
MILITARY EQUIPMENT THAT ARE IN
U.S. STOCKS.
THIS IS A REALLY UNPRECEDENTED
EQUIPMENT IN THE UNITED STATES,
WHICH WE HOPE WILL DETER
RUSSIA'S FUTURE TROOP MOVEMENT.
>> HERE IS TO THE DUBAI AIR SHOW
WHERE THREE MAJOR MILITARY
POWERS ARE SHOWING OFF THEIR
MILITARY HARDWARE.
THE UAE IS A CRUCIAL ALLY FOR
THE U.S. IN THIS REGION.
SO WHY HAS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SLOWED DOWN THE
SALE OF 50 F-35 FIGHTER JETS,
PLUS OTHER MILITARY HARDWARE TO
THE EMIRATES?
>> I JOINED THE BIDEN HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION ON JANUARY 20th
WHEN THE PRESIDENT TOOK OFFICE
AND WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE ANY
COMMITMENTS THAT WERE DONE BY
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION,
THAT WE HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW
THAT WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THEY
REMAIN IN OUR FOREIGN POLICY
INTEREST.
WE TOOK TIME AND WE ANNOUNCED
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MOVING FORWARD.
I THINK THIS WEEK WE WERE
LOOKING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
RECOMMIT TO THAT EFFORT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE OUR AM
ROT
TPARTNERS UNDERSTAND.
>> AND YOU QUOTE SEEK
CLARIFICATIONS TO THE VARIOUS
ASSURANCES THAT WERE MADE TO THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION, THAT
BEING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
YOU MEAN WHAT?
>> I CAN'T GET INTO THE
SPECIFICS OF OUR DIPLOMATIC
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE UNITED
ARAB EMIRATES BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE
HAD WITH EVERY PARTNER PART OF
THE F-35 PROGRAM THAT WANTS TO
USE THE F-35 AND BUY THE F-35,
WE'RE LOOKING TO MAKE SURE THE
TECHNOLOGY SECURITY IS A PART OF
THESE NEGOTIATIONS, PART OF
THESE AGREEMENTS BECAUSE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE WANT TO PROTECT OUR
WAR FIGHTER.
WE WANT TO PROTECT THE COUNTRIES
THAT ARE USING THE F-35.
>> LET'S BE QUITE CLEAR HERE,
DOES THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE UAE'S
GOOD TIES WITH CHINA INCLUDING
USE OF F 5 TECHNOLOGY UNTIL THE
UAE COULD COMPROMISE SECURITY OF
WHAT IS THIS HIGHLY NETWORKED
F-35?
>> WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE F
3 ANYWHERE.
WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION WITH
ALL OF OUR PARTNERS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUTURE OF THE INTERNET IS
SECURE, THAT IT PROVIDES U.S.
COMPANIES WITH THE ASSURANCES,
THAT THEIR INFORMATION IS SECURE
AND DATA IS SECURE AND PRIVACY
IS SECURE.
>> CAN I PUSH YOU ON THIS?
>> SURE.
>> IS IT F-35s BUT NOT BOTH AS
FAR AS THE U.S. IS CONCERNED?
>> THE F-35 IS OUR CROWNED JEWEL
OF THE UNITED STATES OF OUR AIR
FORCE AND SO WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO PROTECT THE TECHNOLOGY
SECURITY FOR ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS.
>> SO THE ANSWER IS YES, AS FAR
AS YOU ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
EMIRATES.
>> THESE ARE THE CONVERSATIONS
WE HAVE WITH THE EMIRATES ABOUT
THE CHOICES THEY CAN MAKE NOW TO
BE SURE THEY CAN BE PART OF THE
F-35 PROGRAM.
>> THE VERY VISIBLE COMPETITION
FROM THE RUSSIANS.
>> I WAS HERE TO WORK WITH U.S.
INDUSTRY.
WE HAD 300 AMERICANS, CIVILIAN
AND MILITARY HERE.
100 COMPANIES TO BE ABLE TO
PROMOTE THEIR PRODUCTS AND WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW -- I
DON'T THINK ANYONE KNOWS HOW
WELL THE RUSSIAN EQUIPMENT
WORKS, THE RUSSIAN SYSTEMS WORK
BUT WE WERE EXCITED BECAUSE ON
THE FLIGHT LINE, THERE WAS A
LINE A MILE LONG TO GET ONTO THE
F-35 MOCKUP.
THE U.S. EQUIPMENT, THERE WAS
HIGH INTEREST.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD --
>> SO SORT OF WANING RELEVANCY
FOR THE U.S., IS IT ACKNOWLEDGES
IT'S DRAWING DOWN ITS MILITARY
PRESENCE IN THIS REGION?
YOU DON'T SENSE IN ANY WAY SORT
OF WANING OF RELEVANCE OF
WASHINGTON?
>> I WOULD SAY THE RELEVANCE
ACTUALLY GOES UP WHEN WE INVEST
IN SECURITY PARTNERSHIPS HERE
AND THAT'S THE GOAL OF THE BIDEN
HARRIS ADMINISTRATION.
>> THE U.S. PLEDGED MORE
MILITARY AID TO LEBANON.
HOW DO YOU EXPECT THAT MONEY TO
BE SPENT?
IT WILL BE SPENT BY THE LEBANESE
ARMED FORCES.
>> YEAH, THE ONLY INSTITUTIONAL
COUNTER WEIGHT WITH A VOID ONLY
FILLED BY HASBALLAH AND THAT'S
THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE WANT TO
SEE